juan rosé dorado merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait en espagne retournement de
situation la justice suspend cette
décision des autorités régionales
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre il faut
comprendre que le tribunal de catalan
effectivement a décidé de suspendre
cette décision du gouvernement catalan
parce que ça touche aux principes
fondamentaux des citoyens et donc ça
serait au gouvernement d établir le
confinement est pas au gouvernement
catalan cela dit ils sont en train dé
négocier pour trouver une solution
juridique à cet imbroglio la réalité
vous l'avez dit c'est vrai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement catalan
souhaite confinée autour de la province
de l'est de la ville de lérida
près de deux cent mille personnes pour
essayer dé contenir le foyer qui s'est
déclarée depuis plusieurs jours dans
cette région ddd catalogne mais il faut
attendre les prochains jours plus tôt
les prochaines heures pour savoir que
sont les décisions qui vont être prises
sachant que les gouvernements autonomes
sont armés avec un certain nombre de
blessures qui pourraient prendre pour
éviter la contagion c'est le cas par
exemple du gouvernement de l'arago qui a
décidé aujourd'hui même des limites et
la mobilité pad est confiné mais des
limiter la mobilité des habitants en
région de l'aragon qui est limitrophe
avec la catalogne et pour ça ils sont
pris des mesures telles que la
limitation des horaires des commerces ou
encore limiter la capacité d'accueil
justement des commerces pour essayer
qu'il y ait moins de monde dans la rue
et qu'il y ait moins de monde dont donc
qui bouche d'un endroit à l'autre
en tout état de cause la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui d'espagne quant à peu
près et 120 foyers décontamination les
uns plus importante que les autres vous
parlez de la catalogne
forcément c'est celui qui est le plus
important aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
dire que derrière cette crise sanitaire
il ya aussi une crise politique avec
cette question de la catalogne qui veut
re confiné sa région sans aucun doute
parce que
à cette crise sanitaire qui est une
réalité on a additionné une crise
économique on a additionné il crise
sociale et effectivement on additionne
où on aggrave encore la crise politique
qui existe depuis plusieurs années
notamment après le référendum à bord t
est organisée par le gouvernement
catalan sur la sur l'indépendance de la
réalité et qui est cette décision prise
par le gouvernement catalan est
contraire au droit espagnol mais encore
une fois je pense que le gouvernement
catalan comme tous les autres
gouvernements régionaux espagnols ont la
possibilité de prendre d'autres mesures
pour éviter le confirme en totale et
confinement total estimé sûr qu'aucun
gouvernement aujourd'hui voudraient voir
notamment parce que ça mettrait en
danger encore plus le tissu économique
de dans ce cas précis de la région de la
catalogne qui a été fortement touchés
mais aussi parce que effectivement
beaucoup beaucoup d'aidé des catalans
beaucoup beaucoup d'espagnols de façon
générale ne souhaite pas revivre ce
confinement qui a été vécu pendant
quatre mois qui était très stricte entre
le mois de mars le 21 juin qu'on se
confirme on s'est terminée donc il faut
trouver une solution politique et
juridique à cet imbroglio qui existe
depuis 24 heures avec la décision du
gouvernement catalan je n'ai aucun doute
qu'ils aient solution va être trouvée
parce que vous l'avez dit
ces deux cent mille personnes qui sont
touchées et par ce confinement s'il
venait à s'est appliqué en france
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
dit leur confinement est la dernière
solution
c'est aussi le point de vue des
autorités espagnoles
c'est effectivement le point de vue des
autorités espagnoles parce que comme je
vous disais il ya cette crise et
sanitaire social et cette crise
économique il faut savoir que le le
chômage en espagne va fortement explosé
à la rentrée du mois de septembre on
parle d'un million et demi de personnes
qui vont se retrouver
certainement au chômage on parle d'une
dette qui à la fin de l'année qui va
toucher près dé qui va vers les 10% et
et un pib qui va chuter des prêts des 15
% et à tout ça effectivement il ya des
solutions
des solutions comme celles qu'on a déjà
pris en espagne là on applique la
politique de gerridae prévenir avant
guérir et qu'est ce que la plupart des
régions espagnoles par exemple on fait
donc depuis quelques jours pas tout
simplement de l'obligation de d'utiliser
le masque par exemple dont la rue à
l'extérieur c'est le cas aujourd'hui des
10 des 17 régions espagnoles
donc effectivement pour éviter le
confinement qui aggraverait la crise
économique qui est déjà présente au
d'espagne il faut appliquer d'autres
mesures et surtout surtout pas appliquer
le nouveau confirmant comme celui que
nous avons vécu pendant quatre mois une
dernière question quelques mots vous
avez le regard à la fois de ce qui se
passe en france vous êtes à paris mais
aussi en espagne comment est-ce que
c'est le confinement locaux en espagne
est ce que selon vous ils peuvent
arriver en france d'après ce que vous
voyez ce que vous observez dans les deux
pays massaïs solution intermédiaire
entre pas confiné et confiné
complètement scellé confinement locaux
on l'a vu d'ailleurs au début de la
crise ça s'était passé du côté des de
l'italie et la menthe et nos ça se passe
du côté de l'espagne la semaine dernière
c'était en galice où près des 70 mille
personnes étaient est confiné et
aujourd'hui on parle de la catalogne
retour des d12 sont 1000
il ya d'autres foyers mais c'est la
seule façon effectivement des pouvoirs
faire vivre d'un côté une économie très
très touché des pouvoirs permettre au
pays de revenir à une économie plus ou
mois qui marche avec l'arrivée des
touristes est encore une fois en
confinement serait il ne met sur
désastreuse au tendon le plan politique
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social
merci beaucoup juan rosé dorado d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste espagnol et vous
êtes à paris